dix mois les eaux ou vendent à la
première fois que tu es interviewait tu
m'as dit qu'est ce que tu aimais pas
chez toi c'est que tu avais une trop
grande bouche
est-ce que tu as changé d'avis ouais tu
l'aiment bien maintenant tu t'y habituer
oui j'ai eu peur c'était petit à
l'époque c'est pour ça que tu vois ça en
fronde et raconte davantage que la
lentille de penny aussi de ne pas voir
cette fin au bout c'est fini
qu'est ce que tu as fait avant nous un
peu plus long mais je n'y passe et plus
tu vas un peu poussé à l'époque tu
trouves
tu as dit c'est chouette d'avoir les
mêmes fantasmes que son partenaire tu as
des fantasmes donne parce qu'en plus les
paroliers qui travaille pour toi sont
souvent des hommes si les fantasmes
d'homme c'est bien pour tous les deux
ouais ouais je suis d'accord et dans une
autre interview je t'avais demander ce
qui plaisait le plus dans la vie que tu
m'a dit écoute ira pas faire de
philosophie baiser c'est les gens à
l'intérieur ça me rassure alors on va
faire une courte interview oui non
entièrement répondre par oui ou par non
est-ce que tu répondes cité des
surprises avec une fille je vois quand
tu vas au hammam non tueur est parente
de réponse est ce que tu es prête à tout
faire si tu aimes oui est-ce que tu
serais pas à faire un film porno si
c'était un grand réalisateur bien sûr
par franck darcel mais si peu je serais
d'accord oui non truc très porno mais
signé d'un grand nom j'aime pas ta
question vaut pas qu'il y ait vraiment
pas ce signé d'un grand nom s'en fou qui
tient une merde mais si c'est un choix
de films pornos mans comme par exemple
empire des sens signe d'accord donc
c'est oui mais oui m'exposer quand je
vais dit d'accord série bon on va
s'arrêter à cause du csa qui passait à
des questions plus soft qu'est ce que
c'est qu'ils te fais rougis au jour
d'aujourd'hui qui pourrait te faire
rougir
moi je vais oser en a mais toi qu'est-ce
qui te ferait rougir quelque chose de
bon chez toi moi j'ai des fois oui je
pique des phares tout le temps à mourir
dans la rue je te jure on va regarder
parce qu'un produit qui empêche les
jambes rougir tu veux on sait pas bien